that's chase young the guy who is
expected to be the second overall pick
in the draft and look Peter Washington
holds that selection for now and and you
always want to keep your options open
you want to see who may blow you away
with an offer you can't refuse it was
Washington who moved up to pick number
two eight years ago and gave up a king's
ransom to get rg3 do you think there's
any way somebody blows the doors off of
Ron Rivera and company to give up the
opportunity to get a guy that a lot of
people think maybe even better than Nick
bow so the second overall pick last year
I think they should try Mike you know
the specter that has been raised to me
over the weekend I didn't write about it
I thought it was gonna be a little bit
alarmist and and writing about something
and raising an issue that is just way
way way premature but I'm telling you
there's some people in the NFL thinking
about it right now what happens if there
is either very little college football
or some de munition of college football
in the fall and you don't really see all
that much of the people who are playing
college football what happens then you
know who and who knows what the NFL is
gonna be but all I'm saying is what if
colleges aren't open or cut or college
football games going to be played if
colleges are not open I mean you know so
there's all these things that you on
April 21st
you simply can't know and I only raise
the specter of uncertainty about
virtually everything of saying that okay
so if next year would be an absolute
incredibly uncertain period in the draft
if there's even gonna be a draft at all
or whatever you just don't know what the
future holds wouldn't that increase the
value of a generational pass rusher that
you could get right now with all the
uncertainty in front of you so whereas
normally you wouldn't think let's just
say for the sake of argument if you're
the you know pick a team if you're the
Baltimore Ravens and you're
picking low in the first round would you
give me your next three ones to move up
to number two to pick chase young now I
doubt they would do that I don't know
that anybody would do that but in my
opinion at the very least Washington
shouldn't fill in the mental card yet
with Chase young I would wait through
late in the day Thursday before I made
an absolute decision on that call and
Peter you make an excellent point about
college football I get so focused on how
the NFL is gonna pull it off this year
based on the pandemic when you hear some
of the things that people like Jack
Swarbrick the Notre Dame athletic
director told Mike Tirico last week
comments from guys like Bob Bulls be the
big 12 Commissioner you can't have
college football where it's just
football but no college if the campuses
are closed right the idea of letting the
football teams in you know that's the
point where they admit wrestling is fake
that's the point where they rip down the
wall and acknowledge right they
acknowledge it's all a business they're
just chasing the dollar and they don't
want to do that because when the world
gets back to normal once you break down
that fourth wall you have to pay the
players once everyone realizes and
everyone admits that it is a billion
dollar machine they're trying to
preserve for 2020 so I'm with you know
college football this fall whether it's
the season gets canceled whether gets
bumped into the spring good luck with
the 20 21 draft if college football is
still happening when it's time for the
draft but but I agree with you those
future picks you don't know what the
hell they're worth because you may have
nothing to base them on you may be
basing your 20 21 draft on 2019 film
which is basically pointless when you
consider how much changes from one year
to the next Mike if you're if you're Ron
Rivera and Kyle Smith in Washington
right now wouldn't you at least pick up
the phone call Chris Greer in Miami
today and say hey Chris you got three
ones this year and two twos you got
two twos and two ones next year so in
the next two years you've got nine picks
in the first and second round you're
gonna use your first pick let's say to
take a quarterback whatever you do at
five you're gonna get your quarterback
maybe you go up to three whatever but
why don't you at least inquire to see if
Miami would be willing willing it's a
sort of pillage three great picks out of
there next two drafts or maybe two great
picks and two twos out of the next two
drafts to get the second pick in the
draft and go get chase young I and again
I've been thinking about this ever since
a couple of teams mention it to me over
the weekend and that is what if college
football really is either doesn't exist
or you can't make many good judgments on
players this fall you know doesn't that
make this year's value of high picks
just a little bit more and especially if
your whole design is to build for the
long haul with great talent I mean
imagine you're Miami and you come out of
here with a quarterback in the future
and this generations best pass rusher
with all with all apologies to the VOSA
brothers it's just I would look into it
anyway just to see if there's anything
there if I'm Washington all the more
reason to get excited about what's
coming on Thursday night because we
don't know what's gonna happen and we
won't know what it happens until it does
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports